[Music]  and i know  you find it hard when you're  apart of all your  [Music]  and i know you feel alone  inside your house no  place of rest  and i know you try your best to do  what's right i know it's tough  but i'm impressed  just know we  feel it too  [Music]  [Music]  and i know that you are scared we  weren't  prepared for what's to come  and what might pass  when i hear you  [Music]  and i know you're feeling guilt  when you're wrapped up in your  quilt your thoughts race fast  just know  [Music]  some days we  just pass through  [Music]  listen to the sounds  of the world's so quiet now  [Music]  so quiet now  [Music]  just now i feel  [Music]  it too  just like i'm  there  with you  [Music]  [Music]  oh